[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
méxico es el país con la mayor tasa de
mortalidad por kobe 19 por cada 100
contagios fallece el 10 por ciento pero
desconocido que la cultura azteca ve de
manera diferente la muerte con sus
tradicionales celebraciones del día de
muertos el misticismo ha influido en la
manera en la que la población se protege
les contamos desde ciudad de méxico
y la crisis en venezuela quedó en
evidencia en la asamblea de general de
la onu si bien juan guaidó es reconocido
como el presidente legítimo por más de
50 países el invitado al acto oficial de
nueva york fue el presidente nicolás
maduro
a poco más de un mes para las elecciones
presidenciales en eeuu en aquí américa
les tenemos un segmento especial sobre
los temas clave de esta contienda entre
donald trump y joe biden por la casa
blanca hoy hablamos de la corte suprema
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal américa es la región
más afectada por el cob y 19 con más de
la mitad de los casos globales alrededor
de 16 millones y de los cinco países con
más muertes tres están en la región eeuu
brasil y méxico- la nación azteca con
más de 75.000 muertes tiene la mayor
tasa de mortalidad en la región de cada
100 contagios más de 10 personas mueren
pero es conocido que los mexicanos ven
la muerte de manera diferente sus
celebraciones del día de muertos marcan
su cultura incluso en tiempos de
pandemia nos lo cuenta nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico mario
carbones
en tiempos de crisis el ingenio de los
mexicanos siempre los ha sacado a flote
y esta pandemia un grupo de artesanos
logró fusionar la protección contra el
coronavirus con una de las tradiciones
más arraigadas en la cultura popular el
día de muertos
francisco henríquez dirige el taller
artístico el volador que cobró auge en
2016 con el desfile del día de muertos
en la película de james bond pero para
subsistir ante la actual crisis le
dirigió su creatividad puso a sus
artesanos a hacer cubrebocas y caretas
rescatando el concepto de sus
tradicionales calaveras que es algo que
no es un producto de primera necesidad
no entonces lo que hicimos pues fue
transformarlo en algo que la gente
pudiera usar para cuidarse y aparte pues
fuera lindo cuando lo usaran normalice
lleva dos décadas elaborando botargas en
este mismo taller y ahora ha tenido que
aprender a hacer algo distinto todos los
eventos masivos este
las producciones de botargas nadie la
requería por lo mismo de que cerraron
por lo de la pandemia y nos tuvimos que
enfocar a hacer este cubrebocas que es
ahorita lo que nos ha estado sosteniendo
bajo el arco
y funcionó
es la pieza clave y además diseñaron
caretas de protección anti cobit con su
sello único y hace la tarea diaria pero
pues iba como más acorde a día de
muertos también ya depende del gusto de
cada quien el taller de empleo a más de
30 familias y todo lo que ahí se diseña
y se elabora es 100% mexicano si el
volador ya era como un gimnasio para la
creatividad para nosotros esto es lo que
nos ha mantenido a flote es lo que nos
ha dado esperanza y fe en que en algún
momento todo esto va a mejorar en esta
próxima celebración de muertos las
tradiciones y el cuidado de la salud van
de la mano y por primera vez en su
historia la asamblea general de la
organización de naciones unidas se
celebró de manera virtual debido a la
crisis sanitaria
con discursos pre grabados desde sus
respectivos países los jefes de estado y
de gobierno participaron en la edición
número 75 del evento en la sesión
inaugural sobre gente de eeuu donald
trump culpó a china de la pandemia del
coronavirus mientras que el mandatario
brasileño jair bolsonaro culpó a los
indígenas de los incendios en la
amazonía pero quizás una de las
intervenciones más polémicas fue la de
venezuela las dificultades que afronta
la comunidad internacional para hacer
frente a la crisis del país suramericano
quedaron en evidencia con la
intervención del presidente nicolás
maduro en la plataforma oficial de la
onu mientras que el que es reconocido
por más de 50 países como el presidente
legítimo
el líder opositor juan guaidó emitió un
mensaje en redes sociales
venezuela protagonizó la segunda jornada
de la asamblea general de la onu en un
largo discurso que duró más del doble
del tiempo que le fue asignado el
presidente nicolás maduro culpó a eeuu
de la crisis en el país y aseguró que
está preparado para resistir sus ataques
dirigidos a expulsarlo del poder lo
mínimo que podemos decir es que ese
impuesto a la desmesura que es el más
terrible de los pecados que parece
haberse apoderado completo de las élites
estadounidense es por ello que la
república bolivariana de venezuela
reitera la necesidad de reivindicar los
principios de respeto a la soberanía un
poco después juan guaidó se dirigía
también al mundo pero a través de las
redes sociales el líder de la oposición
venezolana reconocido por más de 50
países como el presidente legítimo pidió
a la comunidad internacional mantener la
presión a maduro ya que según él la vía
diplomática está agotada hoy les pido
todos los representantes de los estados
miembros que asuman la responsabilidad
de asistir al gobierno legítimo de
venezuela en su misión de proteger al
pueblo de venezuela de salvar a
venezuela y considerar una estrategia
que contemple escenarios luego de
agotado todos los ríos why do reiteró
que su alocusión representaba la
venezuela real y señaló el gobierno de
nicolás maduro de violar los derechos
humanos en línea con el informe de la
misión de la onu en ese país que señaló
el presidente venezolano y otros de sus
funcionarios de ser responsables de
delitos de lesa humanidad empezamos
nuestro segmento especial de aquí
américa camino a la casa blanca el
espacio para revisar los temas clave de
esta contienda entre el presidente de
donald trump y el candidato demócrata
joe biden de cara a las elecciones del 3
de noviembre hoy vamos a hablar del
nuevo campo de batalla la corte suprema
tras la muerte de la jueza ruth báder
ginsburg
la magistrada icono de la lucha por la
igualdad femenina en eeuu murió el 18 de
septiembre y viera un icono pop y al
fallecer fue honrada por miles de
personas en la sede de la corte suprema
en washington y se convirtió en la
primera mujer en recibir honores en el
capitolio
en 2016 en un escenario similar cuando
murió el juez antoñín scalia el
presidente era un demócrata barack obama
quien insistía en la urgencia de la
nominación en la constitución es
bastante clara sobre lo que se supone
que debe suceder ahora cuando se sabe
que cuando hay una vacante en la corte
suprema el presidente de eeuu debe
nominar a alguien mientras que el por
entonces precandidato republicano a la
presidencia de donald trump pedía que se
dilatara el proceso
creo que depende de mitch mcconnell y de
todos los demás detenerlo se llama
demora demora demora
y es que la corte suprema- tiene el
poder de cambiar o derogar una ley e
incluso de decidir una disputada
elección presidencial los nueve jueces
tienen la última palabra en muchos
asuntos políticos dejando el destino de
la nación en sus manos revisemos el rol
de la máxima autoridad judicial
estadounidense en el siguiente informe
es el más alto poder judicial de eeuu
fundada en 1789 la corte suprema es la
máxima voz legal del país y tiene la
última palabra en los casos que se
originan en los tribunales estatales y
federales es la tercera rama del
gobierno federal y es el equilibrio
entre las ramas legislativa y ejecutiva
tienes tres ramas del gobierno federal
en eeuu
tienes la rama ejecutiva que es la casa
blanca todas las agencias y el gobierno
federal tiene la rama legislativa que es
el congreso
y tienes el poder judicial la cúspide
del poder judicial está la corte suprema
gris
donde se interpreta la ley el legislador
por el hambre software ser buy and gertz
cada año los nueve magistrados emiten
una opinión sobre alrededor de 100 casos
algunos alteran para siempre el curso de
la nación como brand contra la junta de
educación que en 1954 integró en las
escuelas públicas a los afroamericanos
el roe versus way que en 1973 legalizó
el aborto bush contra gol que en el 2000
decidió una
presidencial y obergföll versus hotz que
en el 2015 legalizó el matrimonio entre
parejas del mismo sexo
el documento que guía la corte y su
fuente de poder es la constitución de
eeuu pero la forma como son
interpretados sus contenidos es donde
entra la política ser juez de la corte
es un cargo vitalicio que es nominado
por el presidente estadounidense pero
primero debe ser revisado por un comité
judicial del senado que pasa a la
votación del pleno del senado para su
aprobación
tras la muerte del mud vader ginsburg en
la actualidad hay tres jueces liberales
y cinco considerados más conservadores
donald trump ya ha nominado a dos jueces
durante su presidencia new gold switch y
brett carroll si el senado aprueba un
tercer nominado por trump la mayoría
conservadora en la corte se solidificará
aún más abriendo la posibilidad para que
los republicanos finalmente cumplan
alguna promesa de campaña como revocar
el acceso al aborto una decisión que
daría forma a una generación de
estadounidenses
vamos a la capital estadounidense para
hablar con nuestra corresponsal diana
castañeda diana cuéntanos cuál es el
legado de ruth báder ginsburg
hola qué tal pues deja un gran legado en
materia de la protección de los derechos
de minorías y sobre todo la igualdad en
materia de derechos para las mujeres no
solamente abogo por la separación del
estado y de la iglesia también por los
derechos laborales uno de los casos que
es más recordado por ejemplo es del
instituto militar de virginia en donde
su decisión fue crucial para que se
permitiera que mujeres cadetes
ingresarán a este instituto por primera
vez en la historia desde que fue fundado
así que deja un gran legado y lo que
hemos visto durante estos días de cómo
se le ha rendido homenaje la manera en
cómo el féretro también fue llevado al
capitolio y lo que serán ya su uso
digamos su funeral con todos los
protocolos tanto el presidente donde
actúan como joe bayrén asistiendo a la
corte suprema pues muestra también en
parte lo que fue este gran legado diana
y qué impacto tiene la nominación de un
conservador para ocupar su lugar pues
como veíamos ya actualmente la corte
está
hasta por cinco jueces conservadores y
tres liberales
bueno esta conformación de la corte será
fundamental porque va a marcar digamos
la línea de decisiones que puede tomar
el tribunal en las próximas décadas para
los eeuu frente a decisiones importantes
como lo ha hecho anteriormente con temas
como por ejemplo el aborto pero también
es fundamental justo ahora digamos por
esta presión que dicen los demócratas
tiene el presidente de donald trump este
afán para acelerar el proceso de
nominación de confirmación debido a las
elecciones presidenciales y es que
durante esta pandemia es posible que no
se conozcan quién será el presidente de
los eeuu el próximo noviembre 3 y se
tenga que llevar a los días después
contar esas votaciones esos votos que se
hicieron a través de correo y se podría
dar un escenario no está descartado es
sólo uno de los posibles escenarios de
que llegue a ocurrir algo como lo que
ocurrió en el año 2000 entregase al gore
que se llevó a un conteo a un reconteo y
al final terminó la corte suprema-
decidiendo quién era el presidente cinco
votos
favor y 4 en contra de bus y termina
siendo el presidente de los eeuu así que
será fundamental esta composición en
caso de que un escenario así también se
llegar a dar
gracias diana castañeda corresponsal de
france 24 en washington por su
intervención en este segmento especial
de aquí américa camino a la casa blanca
no ustedes gracias por acompañarme en
esta emisión recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho de el coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]